malgré les déclarations encourageantes
de lionel jospin la france est toujours
à la traîne de l'europe une tarification
simplifiée moins cher pour l'utilisation
des réseaux pourrait donner un coup de
pouce laurent fabius se dit favorable
aujourd'hui à une baisse des prix de
connexion et dans les mois prochains
devraient se multiplier des offres
forfaitaires de connexion illimité au
réseau mondial vincent fourcade avec
seulement 8 millions de personnes
reliées à internet
la france est toujours moins branchés
que ses voisins européens
20% des foyers français sont connectés
contre 30% en allemagne et pratiquement
60% en suède
dans une lettre ouverte aux pouvoirs
publics de grands noms de l'internet
français se sont donc inquiété du retard
pris et ne voit qu'une solution pour
démocratiser l'accès au réseau la mise
en place généralisée de forfait de
connexion illimité l'internet illimité a
fait ses preuves à l'étranger a fait ses
preuves aux états unis ça fait ses
preuves au royaume uni je pense qu'il
est tout à fait normal que la france
suive dans cet exemple avec au final
davantage de clients potentiels
paradoxalement le tarif moyen de
connexion français est parmi les plus
faibles d'europe 7 euros et demi pour
douze heures de communication mais le
consommateur serait victime du syndrome
minitel la peur de ne pouvoir maîtriser
le montant de sa facture plus de 80% les
français sont donc favorables au
principe de forfaits illimités mais il
faudrait que france télécom ravey sa
politique en louant ses tuyaux au
forfait et non plus à la durée et si
l'opérateur nous pas encore s'engager
totalement le gouvernement lui a déjà
pris les devants il faudra avant l'été
que france télécom offre un accès
forfaitaire illimité et ça j'en prends
l'engagement
un énorme chantier attend donc france
télécom qui pour faire face à la demande
devra donner plus d'ampleur à son réseau
et engager des dépenses de plusieurs
centaines de millions de francs
voilà